à paris les sites les plus emblématiques
ont été pris d'assaut par les parisiens
mais aussi par les touristes
ainsi la tour eiffel a offert un
spectacle digne d'une carte postale
malgré les nuages qui planaient au
dessus de la dame de fer olivier caroff
et mathieu dreujou 12 heures 22 minutes
50 secondes exactement les clips c'est à
son maximum au dessus de paris
le monde s'est arrêté depuis quelques
minutes au pied de la tour eiffel
personne ou presque pour regarder le
bâtiment le plus célèbre de la capitale
sur le champ de mars des touristes bien
sûr mais aussi quelques vétérans de
l'éclipsé partielle de 61 disparus
ce spectacle certains hésitaient
pourtant à venir le voir un peu de
snobisme peut-être mais la curiosité l'a
emporté
même chose est en fait au contraire plus
été médiatisé moi j'avais envie d'y
aller et je sentais que mon mari avait
envie d'y aller nos amis aussi donc
voilà je suis très contente d'être venue
j'avais jamais vu des clipse il est plus
que temps même les indifférents ce que
l'éclipsé n'empêchera jamais dormir
avaient fait le déplacement
après la tour eiffel montons sur la
butte